hello everyone
i am annam chenyan
and
i am a ceo at five brain we are building
a platform for
engineers
ai engineers and data scientists
basically currently it is supporting for
a development of
data sets in data computer vision
just couple of words about me
i am a physicist in my background and
my background also before starting this
company we i was working in the current
design automation company
then we have sprint of two more
companies in ai whatever so this is new
company and we have been launched about
three moms
and
this topic contains some information
some small research that was done in our
company
the main idea here is how we can use
data analysis to
reduce the data sets
why we need to reduce the data sets
so basically uh here we go
with what is overfitting under fitting
the reasons the redundant data
how we can select the samples from our
data set
and finally we'll under icfr 10
and figure out how we can reduce this
data set to keep the same performance
how much is intelligent ai of course it
depends on the data set that
we it is trained on yeah because
the only the data set quality mainly
defines the our final ai model quality
and
and so it means that we need a lot of
data
and basically
the data
is required for deep learning
deep learning models the supervised data
is required in most of
the
cases when
we are working with production level and
neural networks
and of course
as engineers we always meet the same
problem bias and variance
trade-off
and
where it is again refers to our data
sets our data
i want to one more time mentioned about
the problem with the data is that with
the eventual with supervised learning we
need to
augment the data so we need to label the
data
to clean it and if needed we need to
augment it and then we need to train
so
in
the
trade-off of
variance and device it brings to data it
brings to our overfitting and under
fitting and basically overfitting can
refers to dated redundancy so it means
that we have
what means of what we are calling saying
that redundancy it is about having
identical images
uh that bring little value to our data
set
and this um having a lot of similar
cases let's say our identical cases
this is leading to a bad generalization
of our ai model
and
which is again
based is highly correlated with data set
quality
and from this point it is important to
the to reduce the data set to optimize
the data set so to eliminate the
redundancies from our data sets
and one more thing that
of course we can have good data set but
the uh
our model capability doesn't allow it to
learn
so there is again correlation between a
model capability and the data set
minimum maximum sizes let's say
so because if we have very good data
terabytes of data labeled but our model
it doesn't have enough capability it
means that it will not be able to be
generalized
because it has
low
less weights to keep this information
inside it
this is the idea under that
one more thing that we need to again uh
want to mention why we don't want to
have redundant data it is that because
we have to label the data it is
account is wasting our time let's say
if we have a lot of redundant data then
we need to train on this redundant data
which
again wastes our gpu
and our budget and of course time and
finally we can have that data set it can
overfit
so it means that we need to somehow
find out the reasons and to reduce the
redundancy from the dataset
and before
so we understand for the point that data
data should be optimized that the
dataset should be optimized
and okay now now the question how
do we need to select our data right
in this case we need to answer several
questions like how well is our data set
developed diversified
uh what is the
percentage of redundancy there and
how many rare cases are there because in
real life
it should contain edge cases as well
which in our data set cannot be
available but we need to somehow figure
out what is there
there are main two approaches
to tackle this data set optimization
problem
this it is based on active learning and
corset selection
now let's talk about active learning
okay so what is active learning is about
active learning is about that system
learns
online which samples it is needed
how it is done
so as a
engineer i will label some
some small set
based on that this small set will train
my model
uh evaluates the unlabeled set which is
bigger quite big enough because i have
trained it on very small set
after that after evaluating we'll
query new samples to label based on some
some metric
well i will talk about that metrics as
well
again i i will label that a new set of
labels new set of samples label it add
to my previous samples and have
and decrease my data set with the new
labels new
training set and again continue and here
we have a loop still some kind of
criterium
now
what kind of what is our querying
mechanism to select
the
new samples from our unlabeled set
there are three of them that are
used widely it is
so
it is
based on least confidence
so when we are evaluating on the
unlabeled set from that set we are
selecting the samples that has low
confidence
for example let's for example if we have
for example we have two samples uh one
of them let's say it is about images one
of them is the prediction probability
says that here is a cat with 32 percent
and therefore on the other sample it is
saying that here is a dog with
uh 45 percent then uh we'll select the
first one
because on this we have a
low probability
the second approach we are evaluating
not only the height probabilities that
are predicted by our system we are
evaluating the difference between height
to probabilities let's say we are it is
called margin difference
uh so uh in in the margin
case what we are doing so
now we have again the same scenario we
have two samples one of them is saying
that we have a 32 percent details it is
a cat and 30 percent it is a dog on the
same sample
and for the second sample it is saying
that here i have a 20 percent
cat and
20
20
20
this is a dog as the difference uh is
high for the first some pulse so is low
very low for the first sample so it
afforded the system wasn't able to
figure out which this is a dog or this
is a cat in the second case it was able
to somehow distinguish these
classes that is the reason that we'll
take the first sample
okay this is the other case and so
for in the margin case we are evaluating
two uh classes two probable predictions
and another case is called entropy is
based on entropy when we are taking the
entropy of all predictions
and highest entropy will be high samples
with the highest entropies will be
selected for the training
but and you see here that
with the help of active learning we are
reducing labeling time because not all
the data set is labeled and
during this process we are selecting the
samples based on some criteria which one
we can select for our as a next step
but
as this is a iterative loop
it requires a lot of computational
resources we are iteratively training
the same model
this is
active learning that helps us to to
optimize our data set
um and the uh next
method is corset selection
the corset selection we in the
case of corset selection
we
have where we are labeling the whole
data set
and we work with labeled data set but in
this case
our
goal is to
select the small set from the whole
already labeled data set
uh this is again to uh
flow we are not
reducing the labeling time but we are
with the corset selection we have a
chance to have better data set
and
again reduce the training time
um in both this area that i have
mentioned both in active learning and in
corset selection a lot of research is
done and some of them are shown here
for example here this is these are the
recent
publications in these areas
it is selection via proxy proposed by
coleman guitar
and um
what that do they suggest to do so
they suggest instead of you training our
whole
heavy model they suggest to
use proxy models
and remove the hidden layers most of the
hidden layers and train on that
train on based on that proxy models
with this they have obtained that even
though the error rate is very high
because the model is reduced the hidden
layers are removed they say that
even with this mechanism it is possible
to select
to do quite good data set selection and
this
method they have used both for
active learning and both for
corset selection
the same methodology they that they are
proposing and the other that one
that is
shown here it is deep learning on data
diet
they are asking question how early we
can find out the samples
that we don't need how early we can find
that samples
the idea is there that we can find the
samples during the training
and
if we can evaluate the
learning laws
the difference norm uh l2 l2 difference
between uh predictions and ground troops
and base that information select the
data that is needed and also they are
connecting this with the other
thing that was done it is that
another research has been done and they
they say that
there are some samples that during the
training are
continues to be well
detected and even uh and but in during
in training scienti also notice samples
that are forgotten and they say if
as they have a correlation found a
correlation between between these
forgotten
samples and the quality that they bring
to the data set they found that as they
are forgotten in early stages it means
that they don't bring enough
value to our data set that and we can
remove these samples from our data set
okay so
it means
that
in order to optimize data set we need to
have some kind of metadata
that metadata can be defined by us the
sampling can be done by this metadata
also another research was done that
produces quite good result it is based
on random sampling methods or randomly
objects samples are taken and also we
can do it manually
but
you want to mention that
for example in case of
when we work with videos
in this case
we
are
we have to have
the redundant data because we are
extracting frames for the video from the
video the source is the same and there
are sequences in the videos and we need
to tackle this problem when we are
working videos this is very important
there and when we are working with you
with videos for example with frames from
the videos we can use hash functions
because hash function functions are good
for that we can also use
the other technique that also the
previous techniques that i have
mentioned we can do
take feature extraction with tsne you
may pca and dnn also and also we can
analyze automatic properties of for
example in case of images and videos
[Music]
yeah the hash functions from now i would
more be focused on
classification and detection tasks and
for example the hash functions
you know that these are robust against
changes in brightness contrast and gamma
corrections compressions
this is the problem with hash functions
and not this is not a problem but
whatever this is the
case with the hash functions that they
are robust against the changes
but and these are good for selecting
identical images identical
samples
the other problem that we can have with
hash functions is
that
when we work with big data
we can have collisions in hash values
but in our case we used to work hash
functions for example for per each
video to extra to extract the identical
to remove the identical uh frames for
from the our data set
and it is
quite useful
the other thing that we can do is we can
remove identical
sorry we can remove similar images
uh so with the hash functions we are
able to remove the identical image
images but with
clustering for example we can remove
similar images
so
here again we can use pca hawk features
tcne
and also extract from
deep neural networks
extract features from the deep neural
networks and then run clustering
evaluate our clustering method
and finally with this clustering
from these clusters remove the
similar images that we have noticed
there
here again are shown several researches
that are
done for
a computer vision
community basically
and the last ones semantic redundancies
in image classification data sets uh
they showed that
10
of the data sets are not needed for c4
10 c500 imagenet
the idea is their idea is that
they are evaluating the semantic space
what do they do so they suggest to train
the whole data set train on resnet
and from the
resonant extract
feature vectors
based on that feature vectors they are
creating uh accumulative cloud they are
doing agglomerative clustering based on
cosine metric
and finding the difference and the the
clusters needs to be maximally uh
[Music]
need to have maximal distance
uh what and with this they have obtained
that
here are some
this here is a graphic that shows that
basically for example you see here they
have
reduced uh the data set this is for c410
they have reduced data set up to
55 percent and here is um
result of the
train uh training set uh sorry testing
set for
when the sampling is done based around
random subsets and when the air is done
based on semantic
clustering
and you see that after some points there
is a big difference and for example in
case of
when the data set is 90 percent from see
far so 10 is reduced they have the same
percentage or maybe better um
as 400 percent of data set
so it means that 10 can be reduced from
the data set and with this method they
found that it is better
than doing random sampling
random selection from
the data set
so
we uh
where we're working uh on development of
our platform we're doing reading all
this kind of research and asked
ourselves whether it is possible to
use the meta information extracted
photometric metal information extracted
from the images
and
let's say as we say okay now let's see
how what is the distribution we know
that in case of
image process
image classification object detection
the brightness
has high impact on the quality of the
prediction
and we wanted to figure out what is the
distribution of the brightness and how
it can be useful to reduce our dataset
whether we can use this kind of
information that we have
to reduce uh the c410 for example
dataset
here you can see the sephardium
brightness distribution you see that it
is
quite close to gaussian
the skewness
skewness and cortices are shown here
here are shown
above
just a second
yeah
i have done double here is uh for
seafarton you know maybe you know it can
contain 10 glasses it is 32 32 images
each of them contains
5 000 samples
and the distributions are close to
brightness distributions are close to
gaussian
the same is for the
next five
classes
yeah
and this is shown for the training set
for the validation set which is a
thousand uh which contains thousand
images per class we see that uh the the
gain distributions are
again close to gaussian and
for example mean values are very close
in case of airplane we have a
160.5 and
for the testing set the mean value is
164.6
in case of cats the means are identical
mean is
for the training set it is 131.5
and again for the testing set it is
again the same value
the similar pattern we have noticed uh
for the
the other
next five uh classes
and we want it as we have read the
article that says ten percent uh is
enough it can produce the same quality
uh as
the hundred percent okay we said let's
now remove this ten percent keeping the
balance of the data set
for each class
and
we have here here are histograms of the
brightness and we have cut off
from the highest frequencies
the highest frequencies have been
removed from the data set randomly
um
again
for all
from all labels
yeah
and we have obtained
the we we have evaluated our
reduced data set based on vdg 16.
um we have
both
190
data sets we have trained with the same
learning
rate scheduler with the same vgg 16
parameters hyper parameters and
this is average
values
so
and
obtain the same
accuracy
for the datasets
this is all thank you
[Applause]
myself
hi
is it okay
uh so you talked about hash functions
and
four images and i was wondering what
kind of hash functions have you you know
used or you know
they have been using
if you can elaborate on that a little
more
uh yeah
thank you thanks for the question um
we have used the
uh wavelet base bank uh hash function
and also
using average
average
hash function
so but if you would like i can provide
several hash functions and you can check
which one works for you better
based on what criteria is some of the
core sets selected
of course
it
[Music]
it depends
there are a lot of different cases that
so it can be for example the learning
grades that
learning
error rate
that we are getting
or it can be um
again as i said in the previous example
they were evaluating the clusters
uh the difference of how their distance
is kept within the clusters
to reduce the clustering size let's say
this is another example that we are that
they have done
and
for example how much impact if they are
adding and removing so the checking the
impact of the the of this sample batch
of samples on the data set
um
basically it is done based on clustering
in most of the cases if they are doing
clustering and
the idea there is to
reduce cluster size make it more
distance
increase the distance between the
cluster size basically in case of corset
selection the cloud that we're using
clustering
thank you thank you
okay thank you
[Applause]